when people say Gary do you think the
Creator economy is that I'm like brother
newspapers are being sold today
newspapers I work for one and by the way
I don't say that as a Raz I say that
nothing becomes dead it finds its new
equilibrium we don't sell as many
newspapers as we did in 1950 because a
lot more attention is put into the phone
and the television and the radio and all
these other things that came along but
the newspaper used to be 5 cents you
know I looked the other day I was kind
of in the airport like damn newspaper's
gotten pretty exp and I get it it comes
you got to find your equilibrium to run
a viable business against the cost and
demand and but like this concept of debt
is silly attention is the number one
asset bner Nation how are you super
excited about talking about the history
of the internet and social media uh
always think that the lessons of the
past give us previews to the Future uh
so I'm excited to introduce author
Taylor to uh to the show so Taylor why
don't you tell everybody who you are the
name of the book and why you wrote it
and then let's jam into it yeah um my
name is Taylor Loren I'm a technology
columnist at the Washington Post um and
I wrote this book extremely online uh
because I wanted to sort of talk about
the first 20 years of the Social Web so
it's really about the Rise um of social
media and the content creator industry
um it sort of tells the rise of social
media through the lens of you know these
big content creators that really shaped
the internet and these
platforms what do you think is the
biggest so actually let me take to the
audience audience as a lot of you know
like this has become a real thing and
obviously I also wrote a book there it
is if you're watching visually crush it
which talked a lot about this YouTube
Twitter thing might lead to people being
able to make a living online and I
remember reading the early reviews on
Amazon and people like this is crazy
nobody's gonna make $50,000 a year being
themselves online and to think where we
are all these years later you know what
do you think most people misunderstand
about creators and
influencers from a general public
standpoint yeah I mean I think people
just that that like it has the worst
reputation you know I think people just
think oh it's really easy you're just
taking selfies all day you know how hard
is it to generate content I could you
know YouTube My Life or whatever it's
actually incredibly incredibly hard
you've got to be a great Storyteller
it's an enormous amount of work you know
even if you're just editing stuff um and
so I yeah I just think it gets a little
bit maligned I think people don't
realize that these content creators are
actually sort of real
entrepreneurs yeah I mean I think you
know Donnie Osmond or manuto or New Kids
on the Block right or Samantha from
who's the boss like there was there's an
acceptance that there's been teen stars
in our culture prior to the mature
internet but the size and scale and what
is not deemed as a skill to your point I
don't think people understand at vayer
media we call it sock strategic organic
content there is like deep analytics to
what time you post what is the best
feature that you can use right now like
a two a two image or video carousel
right now on Instagram is outperforming
a regular reals video you know uh being
first on a Tik Tok or a musically five
years ago is going to have more
opportunity and upside of growth than
today so the strategy of understanding
consumer Behavior the thumbnail the
headline the copy the business
development of doing collabs with the
right people at the right time
negotiating with big Brands to do brand
deals I mean there it is truly a high
level of Entrepreneurship but because
the numbers are lucrative and often not
always the people are young there's this
subconscious disrespect for the craft
yes yes
100% yes and I talk also in the book too
about sort of like the industry itself
it was sort of pioneered with people
outside of the sort of mainstream media
system um I actually talked about the
rise of mommy bloggers and kind of how
they you know advertise and commodify
themselves and then early YouTubers and
so I think just a lot of people have
written it off H it reminds me when I
first started writing about the internet
how people used to say you know oh why
you cover YouTube it's just a site for
cat videos you know um and of course
that's just not true anymore and I think
most people wouldn't say that today but
it's reminiscent of how they talk about
Tik Tok right like oh the teen dance app
and it's like well these platforms there
so much more than that you know um but I
think people just still haven't there
yeah there's just not that level of sort
of like what you know it made sense to
me because I obviously grew up in the
game it made sense to me when people
said that about Facebook and Twitter
because they didn't have a comp right
Myspace sold very early Friendster
couldn't stay up you know why do you
think today that that not everyone and
it's evolving and you see that it's
evolving but that many in the general
public even though they've seen YouTube
Twitter Facebook you know snap you know
have longevity be meaningful businesses
go public run you know real businesses
have real Revenue why do you think
people you know inevitably you know this
Taylor like in the next 24 to 72 months
a new app will pop up and it will be
destined to be one of those things and I
kind of believe and I sense that that's
where you were going that again people
will be dismissive and say oh that's
just for people wanting to play games or
like that's only for people who can
write or you know like that's only for
radio personalities if it's an audio
thing like why why with seven to 10
meaningful examples now um that rise
from youth to full mainstream do you
think people continue to be dismissed I
mean when I was yelling about Tik Tok it
was on the back of Instagram and snap
and and I just thought that people would
understand and yet even the people that
were on Instagram and winning as
influencers probably spent a year or two
too late to jump into Tik Tok to get all
the good attention why do you what is
that inuman behavior that continues to
allow them to be dismissive of obvious
results yeah I mean I think a lot of
people are just overwhelmed by
technology and they don't want to feel
like they have to learn a new app you
know they want to just sort of dismiss
it a lot of times as you mentioned these
things are adopted by young people which
people are inherently dismissive of
especially young girls you know like
teen girls they can make an app hugely
viral but you know a lot of people are
just like ah it's just a silly little
you know kids app so I think it's sort
of a combination of those two things
it's just a lot of it's just Tech
fatigue of like oh I don't want to have
to learn oh now I've got to learn Tik
Tok you know and it's like well maybe
you know if you want to take advantage
of it yeah for there's so many content
creators there's so many entrepreneurs
there's so many Fortune 500 Executives
listening to this interview right now
what what do you think is the biggest
value from the book like what do you
what do you think they get out of it and
what do you if you want to double click
into any part of the book like when I
when I set it up that way and you
recognize the size and scale and the and
the and who is in the audience listening
to this right now it you know what is
the value prop for them yeah well I
think there's so many business lessons
in this book I mean one thing that my
book talks about is sort of these
mistakes that these Silicon Valley um
platforms made actually in sort of
misunderstanding their user base
misjudging their creator there's a ton
of unreported information about the end
of Vine actually and sort of the
implications that it has even for
Twitter today I think musk is learning a
lot of the same lessons that the
founders of Vine learned the hard way um
so I think it's a great book for any
kind of anyone that wants to be
entrepreneurial um because it also talks
about the rise of this sort of um
simultaneous industry right the content
creator industry and how people sort of
worked outside the Realms of Silicon
Valley and elsewhere to kind of start
their own businesses build their own
Brands and in really interesting unique
ways um I think this whole the way that
social media emerged and the stories
that have been told um it sort of hasn't
told that other side of it of the user
side so I think you just I think you can
learn so much about kind of even just
where things are going in Tech and media
because that's also what the book is all
about and and how many people have you
spoken to that have read the book like
I'm talking like friends and family and
just like random like what would you say
roughly at this point probably about a
hundred people at this point so that's
perfect I was hoping it was that kind of
number what do you think stands out like
what what have you been because given
that you know I've written six or seven
books now and I'm always it's always so
fun to be like oh man I wasn't even like
like you know you talk to like 20 people
and like seven of them like man I really
like the thing about the canoe and I'm
like what you don't even remember
because you know this it's a forever
process and I'm like the canoe yeah on
page 19 and you go back and you're like
wow that's the thing have you had that
moment is there any anything that you'd
be surprised by or what has stood out to
those hundred people I continually I'm
surprised by this actually because what
you described is exactly what's been
happening um a lot of people are really
surprised at how these companies were
founded like they assumed that YouTube
always was going to be what it was they
didn't realize it started as a dating
site for instance or you know they
didn't they didn't realize that like the
way that Twitter Evol I think a lot of
people have this mythology in their head
around these businesses and this is why
I think it's such a good read because it
really gets into lots of businesses in
one book you know there's the YouTube
book there's the Instagram book there's
a Facebook book I'm like okay those are
great books but you can just read this
book that sort of has like the sort of
the key takeaways of all these platforms
including Snapchat as I mentioned the
live streaming boom what made you now
successful at that you know time in the
mid-2010s how did they lose market share
so yeah and people have gravitated to
those little their little things like
you now is another one they're like oh
yeah I forgot about that I didn't know
people made it living and what that did
to sort of twitch and so yeah it's more
it's more just like a lot of like random
unexpected little yeah makes sense given
that you're a journalist given that
you've been in this obviously I've
watched your career blossoming as
someone who kind of like tries to really
pay attention to [__] like I've always
thought you've done a good job and so
I'm really curious about this
question then this is one woman
subjective point of view this isn't fact
for you as you go through the history of
this last 25 years or so whatever it is
15 20
25 which app or platform are you
personally like disappointed didn't make
it or isn't in the top five
today good or or or you could take
another track you're most surprised that
it didn't make it you understand why
because you've done the research but
you're most still surprised or tell
people a story of like why it should be
here and what the one one bad move was
that changed the course of it yeah um
well you know it's it's that's such a
great question there's a few obviously
Vine I I'm a millennial I grew up on
Vine it makes me so sad that the way
that app was sort of mismanaged that was
that was sold incredibly quickly right
that was within launch pre-launch to
Twitter yeah yeah and then Twitter
mismanaged it I mean I think Vine could
have really rivaled Tik Tok like Vine
Vine was the preview to Tik Tok exactly
you couldn't have Vine without Tik Tok I
also have to say Gary Snapchat like
Snapchat's been a surprising one where
you know it had so much hype and it was
ascendant and then they really also kind
of shot themselves in the foot they to
creaters Let's double click into that
yeah Snapchat today as you know because
you covered a space continues to
dominate messaging between the youth
right yeah yet so many of these 17y olds
will literally talk to all their friends
it is their core it is like hey Elders
without kids or even 20 even 30 year
olds without kids like this is where
they text not on WhatsApp and on you
know
iMessage you know Spotlight is sitting
right down there one click away yeah
which for everybody at home that doesn't
use it which is most by the way which is
the point I'm getting at that is
basically in essence their feed their
Tik Tok their Instagram and you and I
know because we do this for a living the
content in there is very similar to the
content that is in Tik Tok and
Instagram what what do you think snap is
missing or why isn't it have more I
continue to believe that they could take
20% Market sh of the feed economy in a
snap pun intended if they tweaked it a
little bit what's your take on why the
majority of people that consume
Instagram and Tik Tok do not also
consume I mean more of them consume
YouTube shorts for the most into it then
snap highlight when it's sitting right
there they're already there they're in
the room they're in the [__] house
they're just not to the other living
room why yeah I mean I my book actually
sort of talks about evans's
mismanagement of kind of or not I would
say mismanagement he made a series of
decisions that I think sort of set them
up to be in this difficult spot one he
insisted on separating that social
experience and the media consumption
experience I don't know if you remember
I think it was 2017 or 2018 when he
split the two and he sort of talked
about that I think that was a mistake um
and you know even today I it's just they
haven't he's they're sort of very
antisocial in a way like they don't lean
into things that that think you're right
like I am I watch it and I'm like my God
you know you're shooting yourself in the
foot they also alienated their whole
first class of content creators and yes
I know a lot of content creators are
making big money on you know discover
still you know sometime some of them but
I mean that is because it's all supply
and demand and the ones that are going
hard in it there's still plenty of
attention it's just the majority of
creators don't even think to go hard in
it exactly yeah and I think that's
because I think that's because of the
company's history with the creators
where they alienated and sort of they
didn't they had a very hostile
relationship with creators for a while I
mean that whole first generation of
Snapchat creators they didn't want those
people on the platform they wanted it to
be about one to one IRL friends close
friends I think that was a mistake makes
sense what are you here's a fun one I
I'm sure this crosses your mind what do
you think the next snap because kudos to
them they built a great company but to
your point I think both of us kind of in
our stomachs feel like there's more
upside there um what do you think the
next
snap Tik Tok Instagram is like what do
you what do you and this is like I mean
if you really knew you'd be [__]
doing it right d you know what do you
and I so I'm not asking you directly I'm
actually talking more genre I brought up
earlier is it voice is it this like
where do you have
any thoughts on the kind of thing that
is kind of missing in the marketplace or
what kind of aspects of the entrepreneur
Andor the app will be needed to be the
next breakout app yeah or or finally I
apologize because I really want to get
this from you or the common thread of
these 15 to 20 over the last 15 years
that won it do with so much of the
journalistic research you've done is
there any common theme or is it too
contextual moments in time blah blah
blah yeah um there's a few there's a few
sort of answers um number one I think
just in terms of where things are going
one thing that seems interesting to me
is a lot of there there keeps being
these sort of like I think desire for
sort of simultaneous ephemeral
experiences like whether it's voice like
a clubhouse room or rip or like Twitter
spaces and stuff or even just something
like be real where it's sort of about
this like simultaneous online experience
um I think a lot of people even like a
Tik Tok live right it sort of fulfills
that need um so I don't know if we'll
see like a separate app or like feature
sets building into that but that
definitely seems to be like a desire
from users I think for anyone looking to
make the next big social app you're
going to have a lot of competition uh
because you know look Tik Tok had to
spend a billion in marketing alone in
2019 on you know app downloads just to
really kind of compete against Facebook
and Google um but I think there's a lot
more room for small Niche apps and
people want to spend more time with like
sort of restricted communities that's
why you see more people moving into like
Discord and these group chat platforms
um so that's yeah that's interesting I I
would also just say like another lesson
from my book like the one like a big
lesson that I learned from sort of like
watching these companies rise and fall
is to be flexible like be flexible
because these Founders they never
understood sort of like or predicted how
their um products would end up being
used and it's really the founders that
could kind of like roll with it instead
of be like well no but I built the
business for this or I want people to be
be sharing this way why aren't they
doing that instead of being by the way
I'm sorry to jump in rolling with it
everyone is adjusting to the reality yes
it's called being consumer Centric you
know I think Taylor's point is well
taken uh we've talked a little bit about
you know and by the way ev's conviction
uh Evan Spiegel's conviction is also how
he got there in the first place right
like it's like your gift is your curse
at times right and so having that
conviction up front tends to get you
there really taking a step back and
adjusting to the reality of consumer
Behavior becomes a whole new uh skill
set it's C it's counter
punching you know it's it's it's like
Floyd Mayweather more than Mike Mike
Tyson potentially gets you there it's
like you have
conviction of what you're doing and then
as you get into the later rounds aka the
app is a little more mature you're
seeing what consumers are doing with it
now you're kind of rolling with the
punches early Twitter uh anecdote for
that is early
Twitter um the
retweet concept was RT colon and you
would control copy what somebody would
say Twitter's team and those early days
saw that created the retweet button you
know it's it's trying to eliminate
friction from from your consumer or be
okay with who's using your product right
back to consumer goods Christal the
champagne you know really hurt its
business by saying their champagne was
for a certain demo and they had to feel
the ramifications of that you know when
you're an app you know Creator adjusting
to what's actually happening to your
point Nobody Knows the YouTube dating
part and then the next year because I
was there in 2006 was pirated content
yeah yeah I mean it was all family it
was all the Simpsons and you know and
and late night television so these
things
evolve yeah 100% And I think it's as you
mentioned it's really hard especially if
you are an entrepreneur where you built
this product because you want it you
know like to fulfill your need or
something right and like you're like
whoa here's this whole other user base
that I never even expected so yeah that
was a big lesson because the companies
that didn't evolve that way failed very
quickly yeah that makes sense what um
what's most interest what are you most
curious about like what's of the second
because I you know obviously look
everybody who's listening I think you
know what why I like having authors on
is like it's just hard to get indepth I
mean right now one of the biggest issues
in America is headline reading and
jumping to conclusions so you know I'm
famously not a great reader and I don't
tend to read a lot of books and I'm and
I don't really what I do is I'm more
audio I listen I look for social cues
the way I publicly speak is reacting to
the audience but for so many of you
listening book form is a monster and to
me I still think books I'm almost blown
away by this it seems funny because it's
so normalized but like the depth of
content you get in book form for what
ends up being normally under 20 bucks on
Amazon is like pretty profound so people
that want to do the homework I think a
lot of you know I believe the best way
to predict the future is to know the
past and so I think you know Taylor
putting this all together in one place
and grounding it is is something worth
um exploring uh I think will be valuable
for you but knowing that that's a
history context play while you're on the
podcast what about right now what's kind
of like what's intriguing to you like
what are you like uhoh there's some
smoke over there I need to do more
homework like what are you excited to do
homework on as we close out this year
whether it's an app or a genre of apps
or creators or or anything really in
technology yeah I mean I'm just really
interested in kind of seeing Tik Tok
mature obviously and kind of the
business the revenue models I think now
there's this understanding of like okay
creators need to get paid and these
platforms have sort of acknowledged it
and so they're all rolling out these
different Revenue options and I think
it's maturing in a really interesting
way as you mention YouTube shorts is
really T you know taken off in certain
ways and so I think certain people are
monetizing just through that so I'm just
looking more at the revenue streams and
seeing like okay how are people building
these businesses of the future and how
much of it are they relying on the
platforms I think increasingly people
are not relying on the platforms right
they're doing the merch lines and the
product lines and things that are not
necessarily tied to advertising um but
it'll see also I think the strike the
the strike right now happening in
Hollywood is gonna have a big effect on
the entertainment industry I think it's
a huge opportunity for people that make
content on the internet to be honest um
especially next year when there's not
going to be a lot of programming so um
yeah those are things I I'll also just
say one other thing Gary I'm also not a
good like I I like Fast reads I try to
make the biggest compliment and that's
the one thing that I would say all the
people everyone I've talked to they say
it's a fast read and it's a quick I I
tried to make the chapters kind of
bite-sized I do have an audiobook
version um because I'm the same way I'm
like just give me the info like I don't
need all this sort of like fluff around
it let's talk about author life for
actually I have two questions one
actually let me get to my I'll end with
author life because there's a lot of
aspiring authors that I wanted um I
apologize till is this your first book
yes yes it is great so that will make it
even more fun I'll get to that in a
second
Taylor what is the practicality of the
dream that I dreamed and it was really
not a dream it was the observation I
made in 200 um uh when did I write this
book 20 7 2008 when I wrote crushit 2007
I wrote it came out an
'08 what is the realistic nature of the
practicality of somebody making $50,000
a year being a Creator around their
favorite thing in the world Texas
Longhorn football uh raspberry jam
Checkers um The Smurfs you know how you
know we talk about the the Charlie
demillies the Logan these are Mr be
these are Big Enterprises that is cool
and amazing and I'm here for that life
I'm incredibly intrigued by the 11 year
olds at home today who are
destined to live a life where they were
going to just do something they didn't
fully love to pay the mortgage you know
there's stuff that I'm passionate about
with my content which is like [__] the
money like can you find like to be happy
and that comes in so many shapes and
sizes how practical is
it in today and going forward as this
continues to grow the longtail of
creators for people to find you know a
salary that is manageable to live within
40 50 60 70 80 90 100 110,000 a year
income but joy for days because it's
about coin collecting and that's their
like in essence the hobby becoming the
profession because of this
infrastructure how real is it today how
real is it in the future from someone
who's done a lot of work to research it
yeah I mean look it's more competitive
today uh I would say than 2007 or8 but
we also have a lot more tools you don't
need as big of an audience um you know
there's a lot more Revenue options today
so I I think it is practical I mean look
you you're you have to build a media
business so you have to ask yourself can
I build a media business around this
thing that I love and a lot of people
can and there there there just continues
to be opportunity on the internet I have
to laugh because there's this cycle
every two years when people say oh the
influencer industry is dead the Creator
economy is dead media media is not
getting less newspapers are still being
printed yeah that's true when people say
G do you think the Creator economy is
that I'm like brother newspapers are
being sold today newspap I work for one
yeah like and by the way I don't say
that as a Raz I say that nothing becomes
dead it finds its new equilibrium we
don't sell as many newspapers as we did
in 1950 because a lot more attention is
put into the phone and the television
and the radio and all these other things
that came along but the newspaper used
to be 5 cents newspapers are you know I
looked the other day I was kind of in
the airport like damn newspapers gotten
pretty exp and I get it it becomes a you
got to find your equilibrium to run a
viable business against the cost and
demand and but like this concept of debt
is silly it's so silly it's so silly and
again we are getting more and more
online every year media is getting more
and more digital every year so I you
know I think yes I do I definitely think
there's a lot of opportunity and um on
the on the internet in terms of building
content around what you love let's
finish with this to the other side more
people always say Gary why do you write
books you're all digital like because
people read them you know like like yes
I like the opportunity in digital but I
also like the S I hate TV commercials as
a medium but I love the Super Bowl
because that one I think actually gets
consumed so like it all just comes down
to actual consumption and there's an
awful lot of books being read so to that
point no [__] be vulnerable
like how much do you want the book to be
commercially successful out of just
being competitive and wanting it to do
well or or what other goals or what have
you been surprised about going through
this journey as a first-time author
obviously being a journalist you know
it's probably been in the back of your
mind forever will I ever do it will I do
it how will I do it talk to me about
first the vulnerability of it which is
like if it does well if it doesn't do
well getting on lists commercially
successful like that part and then
number two given that I'm assuming but
correct me if I'm wrong if you're
someone who becomes a journalist writing
a book is always in the back of your
mind and what was the biggest surprise
going through the first one yeah well I
you know I I care about the setting sort
of like getting the history out of the
internet I I think every journalist we
write about the things we write about
because we're incredibly passionate
about them so everything I wrote in my
book these are things that I'm really
passionate about this was an internet
that I lived through I did so much
reporting so I just want people to I'm
like guys as you mentioned before
there's actually crazy amount of
information in this book and as a
journalist I want that information out
there I want as many people to read it
as possible I do not care about
credentialism I very anti- credentials
and getting on oh I made the list or
whatever I already wrote for the New
York Times I work there for years I
don't care about you know Silly lists at
all and no one should these are all
silly everyone can be a bestseller today
look go look at Amazon you can be the
best seller in every category that's
silly I just want people to read the
book love it and and talk about it
because I really love to talk about
these things and I want more people to
kind of engage with these things and
take it Ser at at a deeper level instead
of saying yes or no yeah because because
again because there's this rich and
crazy and truly untold history behind a
lot of this stuff and and people see the
success and they say oh yeah well it
probably took off because of this no
there was like there was this whole
other you know like talk a lot about
these like debates and the founders and
just it's there's so much more to the
story than a lot of people know so I
yeah I mean I I wrote the whole book so
I want people to read it and what about
the biggest surprise even though
surprise well it was it um you know
honestly it was trying to it was trying
to whittle it down there was so much
information just trying to like get you
know get it through keep it moving even
though you were accustomed to do that
for an article this was at such a
different scale such a different scale
such different scale but um but no I
mean I've yeah as a journalist you like
to you sort of think about it in the
back of your head but I didn't want to
waste I didn't want to do what a lot of
people do in journalism which is just
sort of do like essentially what could
have been an article as a book you know
because they want to expand out I was
like if I'm going to do a book like I
want it to pack so much in in such a
short time so that people you know
really kind of get it because that's
what I want out of books myself like I'm
like just get it in as much as possible
because we don't have a lot of time you
know these days no I've heard Taylor
thank you so much congrats good luck
thanks for having
me
[Music]
yeah